marine le pen has softened her image and
concentrated her campaign for the
presidency on the soaring cost of living
her far-right national rally party still
promises to crack down on immigration
and stop muslim women from wearing
headscarves in public places but the
focus has been on the struggle to make
ends meet
and le pen has constantly attacked
emmanuel macron where he is perhaps most
vulnerable a common perception he is
emmanuel detached had tried once again
to create division once again had fallen
into outrageousness aggressiveness
brutality by brutalizing me he is in
fact also brutalizing the millions of
voters who voted for me this is a trait
of his character this trait will worsen
if by misfortune emmanuel macron is
re-elected every french person must
think about this
macron's last day of campaigning was in
friendly territory he won the first
round here in fijak in the lot region of
southern france le pen was beaten into
third place by the far left jean-luc
melenchon
here macron was energized casting
sunday's vote as a referendum on
france's place in the world
the 24th of april is a referendum for or
against fidelity to our values to our
history what we really are and what we
are for
so it's all to play for let's go and
show them the 24th of april will be the
start of a new challenging time of
battling of kindness and of ambition for
france and europe
in the 2017 election macron won not only
because he was seen as a new face there
was also a so-called republican front
the idea that people should vote to stop
a far-right candidate seen as a threat
to french democracy in this election
there will again be those who vote to
keep out lepen rather than four macron
this time now
from here there isn't much enthusiasm
for the president and that might affect
who bothers to vote but the latest polls
give macron victory with 57
share of the vote on a turnout of around
72 percent
bernard al-jazeera phasia